y'a pas les ja plus d'émissions tu peux
chanter aujourd'hui pas trop non
si j'ai chanté chez drucker chez
sarah qui sont proposés non oui ouais
c'est pas salé d'affaires c'est toi j'ai
fait oui on s'est posé des questions
mais je me suis posé la question à mes
enfants m'ont extrêmement longtemps
puisque la probable est la preuve de la
première année de star academy ou mail
proposé de le faire j'ai pu j'ai pas
voulu le faire et la deuxième année qui
est de star académie voir proposer de le
faire et là ça a été des pourparlers à
n'en plus finir et finalement j'ai fait
je les fais alors bon on va pas revenir
cdd c'était des discussions même sur
l'éthique c'est que ça de faire star
academy ou pas se faire academy c'est un
prêt une des tic quoi si l'info est ce
qu'il faut cautionner cette émission ou
pas c'est ça le problème c'est ça la
grande histoire donc j'ai des
discussions à n'en plus finir avec
d'autres chanteurs et aussi avec
évidemment avec ma maison me disent que
la maison de disques je trouve que c'est
bien de le faire avec mon entourage ma
famille mais
ma chérie enfin d'aider des gens qui
m'entourent les gens des amis et où on
parle de star académie et c'est est il
devenu une obsession pour moi parce que
j'ai alors c'est ça n'a pas l'air
d'aller nager en train de réfléchir j'ai
la pression il faut que je fasse star
academy et doit en finir décidé c'est
quoi vraiment
ce qui m'a décidé c'est un c'était
j'étais parti pour vraiment pas le faire
je respecte les gens qui ne le font pas
ce qui m'a décidé s'il ya eu quand même
une grosse pression de la maison de
disques et de personnes de mon entourage
il ya les missions et les candidats les
gens qui vont je n'ai aucun jugement sur
les gens qui vont que moi quand j'étais
petit j'ai fait des j'ai passé des
auditions de maisons dit je me suis fait
jeter des voix mais c'était pas mal je
suis allée faire des crochets samray vin
et pain sur la place mallet habib un
crochet ce soir il va d'un haut-parleur
qui était passé ce soir prochain grand
crochet sur la place du marché mammeri
et vas-y mes copains et vas-y tu sûr que
tu vas gagner tout j'y suis allé j'ai
gagné en plus il chantait quoi mettre de
cheveux de chansons c'était j'étais tout
j'étais j'avais 16 ans 17 ans ou du 17
ans et j'ai chanté deux chansons que
j'avais composé paraît timide
timide c'est à dire c'est pas une
semaine sans que ça peut être saisi
timide oui oui timide ça elle ne parle
jamais sauf quand tu es le mur mais elle
ne serait jamais qu'en baissant les yeux
si seulement elle était un peu moins
timide
j'oserais lui parler devant elle je
serai moins stupide c'est une petite
bosse assez bon bref j'ai gagné donc les
candidats la désactiver à l'époque quand
j'avais 17 ans on m'aurait dit qu'il ya
une émission de télé leurs effets je ne
sais pas parce qu'il ya c'est quand même
un reality show faut être dans la dans
le dortoir et tous m'ont sous la douche
en même temps j'aurais peut-être fait je
crois que les futurs cabrel les futurs
goldman il irait à cette émission
gens qui savent quelque chose qui soit
sa colère il répond
je les trouve bien stéréotypé quoi
maintenant mais attention ces mini lara
fabian des militants et ses traditions
la fin de star c'est ça on voyait
arriver dès des gamines qui voulait
chanter du céline durval que la jeune
j'en ai parlé avec henri salvador j'ai
rencontré à l'émission la top of the
pops
lui m'a dit la star academy janet c'est
de la merde et tous ne le fera jamais il
ya des gens qui sont hyper je respecte
pas compris parce que les armes les
arguments qui me donne est
musique vous les comprenez moi j'ai
discuté des arguments pendant des nuits
tout simplement tu sais les arguments
nourrit salvador jeunes je les comprends
mais ça tu l'avais dit
mais là il regarde ses fiches
sans fil s'en fiche et pour être sûr de
ne rien rater de nos latitudes abonnez
vous il m'était impossible eux